non so se ce la faccio
Ciao sono Andrea maroè
sono nato in un vivaio e quindi fin da
bambino arrampicato gli alberi e mi sono
innamorato di loro Poi sono diventato
agronomo arboricoltore e infine
esploratore
proprio così esploratore esploratore
delle grandi chiome degli alberi
all'interno delle foreste delle grandi
foreste di questo mondo perché ancora
oggi esplorare salire a 50 metri sugli
alberi più alti e un mestiere è
abbastanza difficile e non conosciamo
quasi nulla di questi giganti Arbore
sono poco conosciuti quasi quanto le
profondità marine oggi siamo qua nella
quercia di sterpo una fantastico
monumento vegetale una quercia tra le
più grandi d'Italia è vecchia di 600
anni ma è facile da raggiungere possiamo
arrivarci in macchina e anche quasi da
arrampicare perché possiamo arrampicarla
anche addirittura dal suo interno perché
cava
Ma pensate alle mille difficoltà che si
devono incontrare per entrare
all'interno della foresta e poi
arrampicare fino a oltre 40 metri su
questi enormi alberi dovete attraversare
territori come le paludi dove possiamo
incontrare coccodrilli anaconde serpenti
ma anche i territori di caccia di
giaguari le scimmie urlatrici ma anche
le formiche proiettile o nidi di vespe
enormi ma a volte è semplicemente
difficile arrampicarli perché comunque
dovete farlo sotto la pioggia
torrenziale e altre volte Basta
semplicemente una puntura di una piccola
zanzara per ammalarsi anche in modo
grave
ecco Ma Questi alberi Questi alberi sono
in realtà i padri di tutta la foresta
creano una connessione con tutti gli
altri alberi con tutti gli altri esseri
viventi tanto sulle chiome quanto sugli
apparati radicali e quindi è
importantissimo conoscerli Questi alberi
sono anche immensi condomini Dove
abitano migliaia se non milioni di altri
esseri al suo interno Pensate ad esempio
a sui grandi sui grandi rami si forma
una terra che io chiamo la terra del
cielo che è una terra completamente
diversa da quella che troviamo al suolo
Perché si forma con le foglie che si
depositano nel corso di centinaia di
anni all'interno appunto del di questi
rami si creano così dei microambiente
dove vivono e soltanto lì delle
particolari specie di insetti di animali
di microrganismi
ma ancora su queste piante convivono e
vivono insieme altre migliaia di specie
vegetali possiamo incontrare moltissime
epifite bromelie orchidee potus ficus e
all'interno proprio di queste piante si
formano altre nicchie ecologiche per cui
già al giorno d'oggi è praticamente
impossibile sapere quanti animali quanti
esseri ci sono su Questi alberi e
altrettanto facile è scoprire nuove
nuove specie la nostra missione è
individuare cercare i grandi alberi
determinarne la specie misurarli
correttamente georeferenziarli e creare
quasi una carta d'identità degli alberi
del Grande Gigante all'interno della
foresta che condividiamo con le
università l'università poi con i loro
studiosi si occuperanno di eseguire
ulteriori analisi ulteriori ricerche e
in questo caso molto spesso siamo noi
stessi che accompagniamo gli studiosi
fino a oltre le chiome perché possano
lavorare in completa sicurezza anche
appunto in questo ambiente Sicuramente
molto diverso da quello in cui sono
abituati a operare ma nel 2022 è ancora
necessario arrampicare Questi alberi
fino in cima per poi lanciare una
Cordella metrica nel vuoto e prendere
correttamente la misura non si possono
utilizzare i droni i satelliti laser con
tutta la tecnologia che abbiamo sarebbe
forse più semplice
in realtà questa tecnologia non è
sufficiente perché il più delle volte se
siamo dall'alto e misuriamo le chiome
non riusciamo a vedere la base
dell'albero Mentre se siamo a terra
possiamo vedere individuare facilmente
la base ma non riusciamo a misurare
quelli che sono i rami più alti per
questo a volte ci sono degli errori si
compiono degli errori con questi
strumenti anche pari al 10% dell'altezza
ed è un errore molto elevato se pensiamo
che poi questi dati vengono utilizzati
per valutare quelle che è la quantità di
carbonica che i tronchi della foresta
vanno a sottrarre quindi moltiplichiamo
per migliaia e milioni di volte questo
errore e vedrete che anche tutte le
politiche economiche e ambientali che
vengono gestite proprio in base a questi
dati possono venire alterati da una
misurazione errata Ecco per questo
misurare mediante Direct Drop l'altezza
degli alberi è un'operazione scientifica
anche di alto livello e viene utilizzata
proprio dagli enti spaziali dalla NASA
ma anche da altri enti proprio per
tarare i loro sistemi e per misurare in
maniera più corretta le altezze degli
alberi nell'arco di 4 mesi di
esplorazione nel sud America nella
foresta del Sud America siamo riusciti a
misurare in maniera scientifica l'albero
più alto del Perù di quasi 54 metri
abbiamo condotto una serie di analisi
sull'albero più grosso delle Galapagos
addirittura 17 metri di circonferenza
che era stato danneggiato temporale
assieme ai colleghi dell'università di
Chito molto probabilmente abbiamo
scoperto un grandissimo esemplare di
ficus una nuova specie pensate che la
circonferenza alla base è sorpassa i 30
metri ci sono rami di 2 metri di
diametro l'ampiezza della Chioma arriva
a 7000 metri quadrati con l'università
di San Francesco de Quito e quella di
Palermo Stiamo adesso analizzando il DNA
proprio per vedere se siamo in presenza
di una nuova specie Arborea sempre in
Ecuador abbiamo accompagnato dei Biologi
dei primatologi sulle sulle chiome più
alte oltre i 40 metri per installare
delle foto trappole Questo è il primo
esperimento di questo tipo A livello
mondiale nel sud America e permetterà di
riconoscere quella che è la biodiversità
che si svolge su questi enormi alberi
soprattutto da parte animale infine in
Brasile abbiamo insegnato ad arrampicare
ai nativi in maniera sicura gli alberi
per poter raccogliere dei semi semi che
verranno riprodotti dall'istituto terra
circondato da Sebastiano Salgado per
riforestare appunto tutte le enormi
distese che sono state nel tempo
deforestate in Brasile uno dei risultati
più impressionanti è stata la misura di
un grandissimo shivawart con X Ferrer in
termini scientifici misurato in Perù è
un albero straordinario arriva oltre 54
metri
ha un legname durissimo e molto
particolare che viene utilizzato per
creare dei parchi di lusso soprattutto
in Cina e in Europa però dovete pensare
che Questi alberi che vengono abbattuti
sia in maniera legale che in maniera
illegale hanno normalmente tra i mille e
i 1.500 anni non possiamo pensare quindi
che questo sia un prelievo sostenibile
all'interno della foresta amazzonica
Anche perché di questi alberi Ce n'è uno
per ettaro anche meno proprio per questo
lavoriamo all'interno delle foreste
tropicali per conoscerle per studiarle e
per cercare di salvarle proprio perché
non è possibile salvaguardare questa
enorme patrimonio di biodiversità questi
enormi foreste Senza conoscerlo
normalmente pensiamo che la foresta
possa dare moltissimi servizi
ecosistemici e questo è vero non ci dona
solo l'ossigeno perché è in grado di
gestire il clima di produrre il terreno
di
valutare quelli che sono i rapporti tra
i vari esseri viventi vegetali
microscopici e animali e soprattutto
funge da grandissimo sistema tampone
Cioè è in grado di gestire tutte quelle
alterazioni che entrano nel sistema
ecologico Di Gaia per livellarle e
creare appunto un equilibrio dinamico
che è fondamentale per la sussistenza
del nostro pianeta Però l'uomo continua
a distruggere le grandi foreste le
foreste tropicali le foreste boreali
senza pensare che queste foreste sono il
suo futuro pensiamo
orgogliosamente di essere in grado di
ricostruire una foresta Ma è un sistema
così complesso che viene ricostruito
solo in centinaia di anni perché
l'alterazione dovuta alla deforestazione
agli incendi alla sottrazione di terreno
è impressionante e non permette la
ricostruzione in maniera semplice e
facile di una foresta Quindi il nostro
primo obiettivo è quello di
salvaguardare le foreste le foreste
antiche le foreste vecchie le foreste
vergini perché sono quelle in equilibrio
sono quelle che garantiscono i servizi
ecosistemici e garantiscono la loro
funzionalità funzionalità che non può
essere sostituita dall'impianto neppure
di milioni di piccoli alberelli che
forse e se rimarranno forse solo Fra 200
anni saranno in grado di dare alcuni
servizi ecosistemici per cui non bisogna
non dobbiamo abbattere distruggere
prelevare legna o prelevare qualsiasi
cosa da queste foreste antiche dobbiamo
imparare a rispettarle a tutelarle a
salvaguardarle studiandole
perché dobbiamo ricordarci che con tutta
la nostra tecnologia siamo in grado di
rifare la Cattedrale di Notre Dame in
meno di 5 anni ma per fare un albero di
mille anni ci vorranno sempre mille anni